well one of the great things about using
online learning resources especially
with the oli modules as in your course
is that we have a way to instrument or
collect data on students as they're
learning so we can go to look at the
data online to see what your students
have how they've performed what they've
done and remember we also created a
pretest and a post-test so that we can
compare students performance before they
used your modules to their performance
after they use the modules this can be
really helpful because we can see how
they improved we can also see the areas
where they still could use some more
support and that can help us refine the
module of themselves right I'm glad you
thought of setting up that pretest
because is it you know if I only told
using traditional methods I wouldn't
have remembered to set up that pretest
okay great well maybe we should take a
look at your data so here is the post
test data so you can see the number of
students who completed it in the last
version of this course was used and this
part here shows the percent of students
getting each question correct so you can
really see on some of the items they did
really well yes but there are a few
items where students performance was not
so good so sometimes what is a pretty
efficient strategy is to first target
the questions where students performance
was not so high and see if you based on
your experience teaching and your
knowledge of the subject matter can
identify what might be going on if there
was a misconception or if maybe the
material was confusing or if there's
something we might want to do
differently next time yeah so I think we
can look at this question here this is a
question that is what is the value
returned by the following function
mm-hmm it's a common problem students
usually get confused between the
function print and return in a return
statement so it's actually expected I
try to address this in
in the class but the fact that it's
still you know it still shows itself in
the post-test makes me think maybe we
should address it even more carefully we
could now what we can do is we can go
back to do you know where in the course
this material would have been addressed
right the initial module okay so this is
the module where that concept would be
introduced right this learning dashboard
page shows students performance and
their learning during that initial
exposure to that topic so maybe we can
dig in and see is one of these more
relevant to what we just tell this may
be the part okay nice try it so this
shows us in this area students were
answering questions about defining and
using their own straight line functions
using built-in functions now the
built-in functions would be most likely
okay point so we can click on here and
see students performance on those items
in the module was pretty strong right
except for on this one let's do that
yeah let's view it in the course so
that's an interesting phenomenon that
when they're first learning about this
topic and they're focused on it they
seem to be doing quite well but then
when some time goes on right they need
to retain that conceptual understanding
and transfer maybe to a new situation
like that print function it's a common
challenge for students learning to
retain and transfer what they've learned
so giving them even more practice and
more distributed practice might be a
good strategy so I could think of
injecting similar questions in other
modules yes exactly so then they learn
it here and they're doing well but then
you can come back to it and check their
understanding and help them practice it
and refine it and we could see then if
you make that change if the post-test
performance looks better yes let's try
to do that next time yeah